oh who is this isis member
this dude is looking for a new group
that's for sure man
i'm just joking brother thank you for
sending a video in
thank you my question for you guys today
bunk beds y'all [ __ ] with it my lady
friend she puts her feet up here that's
the dope
let me know gang gang buzz bro yeah i
[ __ ] with them when i was 10.
you can't be a grown man with bunk beds
that ain't cool
that's creepy dude also for kids there's
nothing better like my son's assumed
my one son's gonna be five in february
the other one's gonna be uh
he just turned one right when he turns
about two my other son's five
you get those little [ __ ] bunk beds
they bunk up together
share stories at night i don't have to
go in there if somebody's scared
you hit the bunk bed with the slide down
they can slide down
that shit's dope me my brother grew up
with bunk beds but as a grown man dude
but you're out
bunk beds you're out you know what i'm
saying you can't have bunk beds as a
grown ass man
i mean i think bunk beds bunk beds is
nice
because your brother's cloak it's like i
like it because if you have a brother
y'all are in the same room there's a
little bit of distance you're not
in the same bed but you're close enough
to hear each other breathe kind of
it's my it's like uh it's like being gay
kind of but without all the freaking sex
and everything yeah and you still gonna
be on the bottom no matter what you feel
me
nope but what i do feel is i think it's
great man my little nephew said bunk
beds man because here's the thing
you get two beds out of one bed space
yes you got all these
regular beds and you have that air space
yes
so man you got somebody you don't care
about you got somebody that's small put
their little ass up there you know yeah
but this dude
this dude's talking about his girl
sleeps on the top
yeah dude that's great i don't want my
freaking girl my hot girlfriend who's
98.6 degrees
[ __ ] snuggling up to my ass like some
kind of little [ __ ] baby forest fire
[ __ ] get upstairs
that's what i was saying dude you
staying on the bottom bunk huh
oh i'm bottom i'm not climbing up there
because it also the ladder hurts the
middle of my feet while i climb
good call bro good [ __ ] call
god i don't like those ladders either
the middle of your foot there's nothing
more
sensitive than that middle foot it's
tender
it's almost like veal you feel me oh
it's like having a little dick hidden in
the middle
inside of each one of your feet yeah
it's like your nut sack between your
feet
yeah yeah dude bro it's basically like
the taint of your foot
after like that middle part got to be
careful god and
you go up there and then you have to get
going up isn't as bad but coming down
and it's dark and you have to pee
you don't know what's going on you don't
know even what's real anymore
getting down when you have to pee is the
absolute worst freshman year
you uh you had the option you could loft
your your beds or you could bunk them
my roommate like volunteered to take the
top bunk so we could have more room
i came home after a weekend i was gone
and i came back and i laid in my bed and
it was all wet
and i looked on the wall this blackout
drunk had thrown up in his top bunk and
puked all down the side of my bed
uh i left i was like clean it or i'm
gonna kick your ass and then
when it came back we lofted the beds
amateur hour man
no more bunk beds shut up actually very
what's his name hunter pence hunter
friends fritz
hunter fritz the old vomit hunter
friends
fritz hunter frets fritz f-r-i-t-z
sounds like he's gonna try blowing up
the att building
uh he he was actually pretty dope though
he he really contributed to my gambling
addiction
he won like a hundred thousand dollars
in the beginning of freshman year and
then he bought my meals for the rest of
the year because we didn't have service
so as long as i went to the quad where
we could get service and ordered the
delivery
i got to eat for free oh type movie it
was awesome shout out to the quad
good time and how's hunter doing now you
think he would call in uh
yeah i think hunter would definitely
he's doing like
loans or mortgage loans he cleaned he's
got a regular job now
he's called [ __ ] ass up what's up with
the bunk beds now
hunter yeah yeah and what happened with
the uh
gambling i wonder how that went like
overall especially if you had that big
win what was the long-term effect of it
yeah
do you have a drug addiction after the
uh all that money
no we just smoked a lot of weed together
uh he that's drugs he was playing
it's drugs uh he was playing like 12
hours a day
so he probably got a bunch of [ __ ]
being that rich in college right i think
he
would maybe if he was like he'd black
out too fast i think he
could have maybe if he like ran a little
game kept himself under control
was it was he built like armadillo would
he look like yeah
oh okay there you go i knew what was
going on there i could tell you're
beating around the bush there a little
bit
yeah he's a good guy yeah it's hard to
it's hard to [ __ ] be unconscious at
the same time man
um i'll say this though
i think uh what was this guy asking if
you can be upstairs oh bunk beds
yeah as grown man you can't be you can't
be in bunk beds man for kids
it does kind of take me back to a nice
time i do like the idea of it every now
and then
i slept in it a couple nights during the
christmas holidays it was good
but yeah i think it's weird if you bring
a lady home and you have bunk beds it's
gonna be
alarming agreed
[Music]
is